bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france l interdiction des manifestations
et des rassemblements en tunisie vous
semble-t-elle justifiée
oui absolument parce que il ya des
personnes qui parlent d'une seconde
vague en réalité il n'ya pas vraiment
une
de premières vagues il ya une
cinquantaine de morts entre mars et juin
et il ya eu à peu près la moitié de ces
morts cette semaine c'est à dire en une
semaine il ya eu à peu près la moitié de
démence qu'on a eu en trois mois et il
ya eu un certain relâchement des le
déconfinement et avec l'ouverture des
frontières en juin et donc avec la
saison estivale qui a fait que le nombre
de contaminations à augmenter et devient
très préoccupant et dépasse largement ce
qu'on a pu connaître au printemps
dernier alors le premier ministre
tunisien a estimé que le pays n'était
pas n'avait pas la capacité de supporter
un confinement générale l'économie
tunisienne ne font relèverait pas ah oui
absolument déjà le premier confinement
qui a duré il est plusieurs étapes mais
qui a duré grosso modo un mois et demi a
eu des effets délétères sur sur la
croissance alors les chiffres diffèrent
d'un institut à l'autre mais mais on est
enfin il va y avoir une forte récession
donc un arrêt total de l'économie tel
qu'il a pu être envisagé était qu'il a
été mis en place en mars dernier en
avril dernier ne semble plus
envisageable donc comme on l'a entendu
le premier ministre est vraiment sur une
ligne de crête où l'urgence où il ya
véritablement une urgence sanitaire une
fois absolument arrêter ou en tout cas
retourner cette courbe et en même temps
l'économie qui déjà bien avant le colis
était exemple ne pourrais absolument pas
supporter un arrêt total et donc voilà
les choix sont limités mais cette
disons que ce choix là semble le maximum
qu'on puisse faire pour éviter un
blocage total de l'économie du pays qui
serait qui auraient des effets délétères
alors pas de confinement général mais
déconfinement locaux qui pourront être
décidées par les autorités locales
est ce qu'il ya des régions à plus
exposée que d'autres au co vide en
tunisie oui absolument et à peu près le
quart de la population qui est concentré
sur la région capitale donc sur une sur
le grand tunis et comme l'indiqué votre
votre invité monsieur riches mélodies et
de l'institut pasteur c'est cette région
et la région du littoral est donc ce
qu'on appelle le sahel qui est la plus
touchée
si donc c'est là où il y a pour tunis
qui a effacé la capitale économique et
politique du pays où il ya le quart de
la population la région du sahel c'est
la région où il ya énormément de
l'industrie également de deux sites de
sites touristiques et donc c'est ici que
là la situation semble là en tout cas la
moins maîtrisée et c'est là que vont
intervenir ou qu interviennent déjà des
couvre-feux et éventuellement des condés
confinement ciblées et aussi la région
centrale de sidi bouzid berceau de la
révolution où on a déjà décrété un
couvre-feu et certainement il va y avoir
un confinement localisées au niveau soit
du département soit 2 soit ceux de la
ville alors pour faire face à cette
résurgence de l'épidémie constatée
depuis début septembre le gouvernement
tunisien promet une augmentation du
nombre de lits en réanimation d'ici à
novembre
concrètement qu'est ce qui a déjà été
entrepris dans le pays alors il ya eu il
ya eu des aides
il ya eu deux types dead c'est à dire il
ya un fond de solidarité qui a été qui a
été créé qui ont été collectés
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de dinars
et il ya eu des aspects s'il ya eu des
aides au développement mais après on
parle du système de santé qui était déjà
à bout de souffle avant avant la crise
donc il est très difficile de changer de
tout chambouler en quelques mois le
premier ministre parle du triplement du
nombre de de restaurer de respirateurs
dans les hôpitaux publics d'un effort
qui sera également demandé aux aux
cliniques privées
mais nous avons un système de santé qui
a déjà à montrer qui a déjà montré ses
limites et qui ne peut pas être réformé
du jour au lendemain
donc là l'idée de parer au plus urgent
de de faire face tenter de faire face à
cette crise là mais évidemment il est
impossible de transformer un système qui
est grippé depuis depuis des années de
le transformer en très peu de temps donc
là là une urgence et de voilà de
d'ouvrir des lits en réanimation comme
je vous ai dit de tripler le nombre de
places le nombre de respirateurs pour
faire face à cette à cette vague et
après il faudrait sans doute remettre à
plat tout le système de santé mais c'est
vous comprenez bien c'est quelque chose
qui peut pas se faire en quelques mois
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions at elle marqué
et essayiste auteur de cet ouvrage
tunisie elle dessine moi une révolution